uh there are a number
of new members of the house of
representatives
who really should already resign or be
impeached
and at the very top of that list of that
list
is a congresswoman lauren bobert some
people are calling her
bobo the clown that we're not doing that
but there are people who are doing that
her name is lauren bobert
she is one of the people who objected to
having to go through a metal detector to
get onto the house floor
she wants to be armed on the house floor
yada yada yada okay that's the person
i'm talking about and
allegations have been swirling that
she may have been complicit in the
riotous
pro-trump insurrection on january 6th
by having given tours to the
eventual radical insurrectionists of the
capitol building
in the lead-up to the january 6th riots
now we already heard for example
from congressman james clyburn who said
listen i have a marked office
and i also have an unmarked office where
i work as majority
whip or whip as frank underwood would
say
um somehow they knew to go right to my
unmarked office that's weird
and on the other side of this puzzle are
the allegations that lauren bobert was
indeed
giving constituents tours of the capital
which would be one way
that the insurrectionists would know
exactly where to go she has denied it
but democratic congressman steve cohen
was
interviewed about it and says very
clearly
he saw lauren bobert leading a large
group
through the capital in the days before
the riots
he can't say these were the
insurrectionists he's not at a point
where he can say that
but it would at least directly
contradict lauren bobert's claim
that she did no such thing let's take a
look at the video
that's remarkable remarkable to hear i
want to ask you about something specific
because several of your colleagues have
alleged that the rioters
may have received inside help include
including
raising the prospect of tours conducted
or with the okay
of fellow sitting members of congress
this is quite a charge to make
have you seen any hard evidence to
substantiate that allegation
only thing that i've seen at congressman
yarmouth refreshed my recollection
yesterday
we saw congressman bobert uh taking a
group of people for a tour
sometime after the third and before the
six i don't remember the day
we were walking in my model we saw her
and commented that
she was and she had a large group of
women now whether
they were people that they're all uh
you know he wasn't had a large number of
people coming to
be with her on this historic occasion
and just wanting to give them the
opportunity to have a tour
but it's pretty clear that her team is
the team
she's not on the home team she was with
the visitors so lauren beaubert is
denying this
and there's a few different things here
that might be going on because
there's cameras everywhere there's guest
books
there it is certainly knowable whether
lauren bobert was leading a crowd
of people whether it was an official
tour or something else around the
capitol
this is information authorities are able
to get so why hasn't anyone come out and
said
we have the video she did do it or we've
reviewed
she didn't do it excuse me one idea
is that the feds much like they often do
are waiting for her to
make specific claims that are lies
before they present her with the
evidence to the contrary
there's maybe a political aspect to it
one idea i got an email from someone
saying you know maybe the feds
are waiting to release the evidence that
lauren beaubert did this
for the inauguration simply to prevent
any even
minute possibility that trump would
think
to pardon her uh maybe they're waiting
for the evidence to pile up and for her
to lie about it
but there is uh no
doubt that it is knowable whether lauren
beaubert and other members of congress
were giving tours through the capitol
and by the way
if it's all recorded it's probably
knowable whether the people that she was
allegedly giving a tour to were later
involved in the january 6th
riots so for a ton of this stuff just in
general
these questions apply to the trump
family investigations as well
it makes some sense to wait until after
the inauguration to really scale up the
investigations into trump organization
criminal and financial
wrongdoing uh just so that donald
trump's presidential power is over
um i i as i said earlier we are going to
see the trump family hit with many
investigations as well
but this needs to be figured out lauren
bobert's office did not immediately
respond to questions from talking points
memo
about you know she denies that there was
a tour
but steve cohen says he saw her doing it
how could both be true do you have a
comment no comment so far
but if we're looking for any signal
about what may be to come
lauren beaubert's communications
director
has already quit now i know you're
saying she's been in office a few days
what do you mean
yes lauren bobert's communications
director has already quit
now in terms of the broader issue of
some of these wacky new
members of congress um we've got lauren
bobert
we have marjorie taylor greene i call
her cue a non-congresswoman
there's this guy madison cawthorne who
has talked about
having multiple firearms on him on his
wheelchair
when he's on the floor of the house of
representatives this is a very bad
direction for the country to be going in
and my instinct is when it comes to
bobert versus marjorie taylor green
i want you to gut-check me on this and i
tweeted about this over the weekend
when i see lauren bober i see someone
who is more of an opportunist and who
may go
too far and end up in prison or expelled
from congress for her antics
but i see her more as a calculated
opportunist
marjorie taylor green i see as an actual
committed q a nut who really has drank
the kool-aid
and i could see her either as a cult
member or even a cult leader although
she doesn't necessarily seem smart
enough to be a cult leader and it
doesn't seem
manipulative enough to be a cult leader
but that's where i see the difference
between lauren beaubert and marjorie
taylor green
let me know your thoughts i'm curious to
see where you fall on this